OFF THE FAR BOARD
BROWNS, SHARP ANGLE GOING ACROSS
THE CREASE AND OUT THE OTHERILLR
PLAYERS GOING ON ATTACK. BEHIND.
THE JETS TURNED OVER, LAURI
BUSTING IN AND SHOOTINGIE OUT T.
BEARING DOWN ONGHT ON ONE
SIDE OF THE NET BUT THAT PLAY
S.
HE GOES NEUTRAL ZONE AND WATCH F
THE ZONE. HUGE
BOOST COMING INTO THE GAME 31ST
OUTE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
GUYS, BACK TOELECTS AND GOES TOW
YOU IN GETTING HURT.
HEK OUT OF MIDAIR.
ERICED AGAIN BY WINNIPEG NOT
OUT.
FLIPPED DOWN BY ANYBODY HE SO SG
DOWN LOW.
WATCH THIS, FIRST COUPLE SING TD
DISRUPTING THE
STOPPAGE. TO SPEAK, HE WILL
BE A SKATES.
EHLERS, TOP UNIT REMAINS ON FOR
THE ZONE, BACK
TO EVEN STRENGTH
LIZOTTE GETS THERE PUCK BUT THE
PATIENCE TAKE OVER A PERIOD OF
FAKED I'M SURE FROM GAMEE. AGAIS
HEAD WAS NOT NECESSARILY UP THE
WHOLE WAY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS A
EHLERS, HARD AROUND, COLLECTED
BY CONNOR ON THE
PENALTY COMES BACK TO HAUNT THE.
EITHER GET A CHANCE, EITHER LEA.
>> Jim: BIG
RED LINE.
KOPITAR, BACK